c'est parti nouvelle année nouvel
arrivage de petit monstre de 10 ans on
pr les mê on recommence vous présenter
les mascottes de la
classardome
JEI lard l'air très
vieux tu troues que j'ai l'air vieux
merci
aucun animal n'a envie d'être enfermé
j'ai raté ma vie cette année chacun
d'entre vousorter une mascotte à la
maison pendant le weekend maintenant ou
jamais je vais aller avec un DEES
enfants je vais m'échapper et je vais
enfin vivre à nous de
jouer un petit Godzilla cétait quoi ça
tu viens de parler
maman personne ne doit être au courant
pourquoi tes pâtes sont mouillées elles
sont naturellement
humides tu le parle c'est ça ces enfants
profitent de mes 74 années de sagesse
tout leou que je suis bizarre les autres
élèves te connaissent même pas Essie de
faire
ça
attendez
[Musique]
Léo c'est le premier normalement il
arrive devant mais tout va bien tu
grandis non non non c'est mon père ah
[Musique]
oui qui a-t-il de si particulier ce
reptile tu m'as fait comprendre que je
pouvais accomplir tout ce que je voulais
ça va mal
finir je sais c'est difficile mais ce
sont les meilleures années de ta vie
crois-moi sur
parole je suis le maître du
[Musique]
monde